[Musik]
[Applaus]
über den wolken das ist das motto der
nächsten air power wie geht es wohl
einen piloten der sohn am himmel ist wie
spielen hier mensch und maschine
zusammen herzlich willkommen hier am red
bull ring in spielberg meine damen und
herren und herzlich willkommen auch die
flieger freunde die heute via internet
mit bei uns dabei sind mein name ist ute
axmann und wir wollen ihnen heute
präsentieren was die nächste er bau so
alles bringen wird was sie da alles
erwarten wird und daher möchte ich ihnen
gleich die gesprächspartner podium
vorstellen ich mache das gleich in der
reihenfolge wie sie so eine mir stehen
daher beginne ich mit dem marketingchef
und red bull magister alexander steirer
dann die verteidigungsministerien
magister klaudia tanner vom
österreichischen bundesheer dann kommt
sie in vertretung des landeshauptmanns
die tourismus wirtschaft forschung und
wissenschaftslandesrätin magister
barbara familie und in vertretung des
stellvertretern landeshauptmanns sp
klubobmann johannes schwarz vielen dank
fürs kommen ja wie ich möchte beginnen
mit dem ersten
partner dem österreichischen bundesheer
frau verteidigungsministerien die
airpower findet dann zum zehnten mal
statt was wird das bundesheer diesmal zu
bieten haben und wie wir die
veranstaltung so ablaufen
landesrätin her klubobmann
magister sehr geehrte damen und herren
vertreter der medien der wirtschaft das
ist ein großer tag der freude heute weil
wir gemeinsam verkünden dürfen dass es
im nächsten jahr 20 22 wieder so weit
sein wird es wird eine power geben und
zwar am zweiten und am dritten september
und um die frage zu beantworten
was haben wir uns gemeinsam
überlegt das wird ohne zweifel eine
veranstaltung für die gesamte familie
werden es wird eine ein umfangreiches
programm geben ein programm am boden
geben in der luft geben es werden 200
zivil und militär luftfahrzeuge aus rund
20 nationen ihr können zeigen das heißt
zum einen eine militärische
leistungsschau am flugplatz gelände
vorführungen unserer österreichischen
luftstreitkräfte auch internationaler
militärische kunstflugstaffel
teilnehmer aus dem bereich der
zivilluftfahrt ja und was auch etwas
besonderes ist es wird eine statische
schau geben von zivilen ausstellern aus
den bereichen der luftfahrtindustrie
sind ja einige auch hier aus dem bereich
forschung und lehre und man kann
natürlich auch das militär luftfahrt
museum besuchen über den wolken unsere
piloten piloten wollen das was sie in
wahrheit tagtäglich machen was wir hier
auch schon erleben durften nicht nur
hier im video sondern hier auch schon
live erleben durften genau das wollen
sie ihre leistungen ihre kunstfertigkeit
in der handhabung der fluggeräte sowohl
durch die flüge eben in der luft als
auch dann am boden beim statischen
display oder natürlich auch bei
gesprächen und sie haben schon
angesprochen es ist die zehnte erbe hier
in der steiermark eine der größten
flugshow in europa mit etwa
300.000 besucherinnen und besuchern an
den beiden tagen der veranstaltung und
wir werden dieses großevent in bewährter
zusammenarbeit und da an dieser stelle
ein ganz ganz großes dankeschön an
unsere partner
red bull und das land steiermark
durchführen für unser als bundesheer als
verteidigungsressort die airpower ihr
habt noch viel mehr als nur eine
veranstaltung in wahrheit ist das auch
eine militärische großübung und als
solche ist sie auch zu sehen das beginnt
bei der führung das beginnt bei der
planung geht über die vorbereitung bis
dann hin zur abwicklung unter zur
durchführung der veranstaltung und was
wir auch nutzen werden ohne zweifel ist
dass wir die große bandbreite
zeigen die das bundesheer auch als
dienstgeber zu bieten hat wenn wir
bilden ja auch lehrlinge aus dass er an
dieser stelle auch noch einmal betont in
den flieger werften und die
veranstaltung spiegelt er auch alle
berufsmöglichkeiten die man beim
bundesheer hat wieder das beginnt beim
koch geht über den mechaniker bis zum
piloten und wir wollen damit auch dem
publikum zeigen welche chancen es beim
bundesheer gibt welche berufschancen es
gibt und was auch wichtig ist es ist
notwendig bei derartigen
großveranstaltungen intensiv
zusammenzuarbeiten intensiv
zusammenzuarbeiten mit den zivilen
behörden mit dem blaulicht
organisationen auch das muss geübt
werden für szenarien und für all die
herausforderungen
denen wir ja immer wieder begegnen wenn
die pandemie geht wenn so ein blackout
geht aber auch um
naturkatastrophe und ich habe schon kurz
angesprochen den wichtigen punkt auch da
der ausstellung der österreichischen und
der internationalen technologie und der
wirtschaft des luftfahrtsektors klar die
an dieser stelle wir laden an dieser
stelle die österreichische wirtschaft
auch ein ihre neuesten luftfahrt
relevanten technologien entwicklungen
und auch innovationen zu präsentieren um
sich natürlich diese möglichkeit besteht
ja auch und ist etwas ganz wichtiges
auch international auszutauschen zu
vernetzen
zum wohle der österreichischen
wirtschaft und es wird ohne zweifel
neben den klassischen themen der
luftfahrt- dann auch ein besonderes
augenmerk auf den future technologies
liegen das heißt forschung entwicklung
innovation für nachhaltige natürlich
auch für klimaschonende luftfahrt und
wenn ich bei diesem thema schon bin dann
da auch gleich offene worte dazu wir
haben uns gemeinsam vorgenommen dass wir
durch ein team von spezialisten für den
bereich umweltschutz und nachhaltigkeit
und unterstützung wohl bereits jetzt bei
der planung legen wir besonderen wert
auf nachhaltigkeit
wir werden die aspekte klimaschutz
umweltschutz nachhaltigkeit
ressourcenschonung
nicht nur bedenken sondern diese auch
umsetzen das heißt zum beispiel dass wir
darauf schauen werden dass möglichst
viele menschen mit den öffentlichen
verkehrsmitteln mit shuttledienst mit
co2 neutralen fahrzeugen bahn fahre dann
kommen wir werden eine kooperation mit
den öbb eingehen anreize schaffen für
die besucher und was die eingesetzten
flugzeuge selbst anbetrifft so ist auch
wichtig eines festzuhalten dass im
rahmen des freigegebenen flugstunden
kontingents die airpower durchgeführt
wird das heißt es werden dann im jahr
2022 keine zusätzlichen flugstunden
absolviert das heißt das angebot
klimaverträglicher produkte wird weiter
gelebt wir werden dies bei den
ausschreibungen
berücksichtigen so diese notwendig sind
wir werden plastik vermeiden recycelbare
materialien
vorschreiben und sorgsam umgehen einfach
mit den ressourcen wasser strom und
energie an dieser stelle eben auch ein
ganz großes dankeschön an die partner
wir tragen ja auch die kosten gemeinsam
gemeinsam mit unseren partnern mit dem
land steiermark und mit red bull zu
gleichen teilen
und wenn ich an den großen ausbildungs
wert dieser veranstaltung er denke auch
für uns für das bundesheer dann wäre das
sonst nur durch eigene und sehr
kostenintensive übungen abzudecken was
man ohne zweifel nicht vergessen darf
dass all die aufgaben großteils der
region zugute kommen aber da wird die
frau landesrätin der reeperbahn mit
sicherheit noch näher darauf eingehen
ich freue mich darauf nach dem was wir
heute schon gesehen haben und schließe
noch einmal mit einem ganz großen
dankeschön an unsere beiden partner das
land steiermark und red bull das heißt
aus militärischer sicht ist das sowie
eine live übung bei dem ein publikum
dabei ich möchte jetzt aber doch noch
eine frage nach fragen dann noch mal und
zwar sie haben erwähnt dass es eigene
spezialisten geben wir für umweltschutz
und nachhaltigkeit die während der
vorbereitungen der power ihren rat geben
um sie damals aber auch noch gesagt dass
es ein besonderes augenmerk auf future
technologies gehen wird können sie das
etwas neue erklären wahrscheinlich
könnte das könnten dass einige im raum
noch noch mehr erklären die genau dieser
sparte kommen nämlich es geht darum in
der luft vater die modernen
entwicklungen auch ins zentrum zu
stellen und das soll der schwerpunkt
sozusagen dieser ausstellung auch seien
daher auch die einladung an die
unternehmen die sich hier intensiv schon
damit beschäftigt haben mit neuen
innovationen
technologien und strategien
electric aircraft ist zum beispiel eines
davon erbe mehr mobilität da könnte man
wahrscheinlich noch sehr viele sagen
dazu das ist in vorbereitung und wird
ohne zweifel einer der schwerpunkte
seien vielen dank frau landesrätin die
bei jedes mal wenn es die airpower gibt
kommen tausende von menschen zu dieser
veranstaltung warum ist diese
veranstaltung so wichtig für die
steiermark und warum ist es so wichtig
gerade für diese region
geschätzte frau bundesministerin werte
partner hier am podium meine sehr
geehrten damen und herren wenn ich
gleich auf diese region das urteil zu
sprechen kommen darf so kann man
wirklich sagen dass ich diese region in
den vergangenen zehn jahren seit der
wiedereröffnung dieses reports ein stück
weit neu erfunden hat denn der tourismus
hat mittlerweile in dieser region ein
ganz wichtiges zusätzliches standbein
eingenommen und das ist ganz stark mit
den großveranstaltungen hier am ring
aber auch mit der airpower entsprechend
verknüpft und wird auch in zukunft in
der neuen erlebnisregion urteil die sap
erster oktober hier geben wird einen
ganz großen schwerpunkt einnehmen es
braucht gerade jetzt nach den
schwierigen kubik monaten wichtige
wirtschaftliche impulse um die positiven
wirtschaftlichen effekte der airpower
sind nachweislich gegeben
wir können mit vielen zusätzlichen
nächtigungen rechnen wir haben die
möglichkeit das urteil und die
steiermark wieder in ein internationales
schaufenster zu stellen und eine studie
hat errechnet dass wir durch die
airpower mit einer zusätzlichen
wertschöpfung für die steiermark von
neun millionen euro rechnen können für
ganz österreich liegt dieser wert sogar
bei zwölf millionen euro also man sieht
die wirklich positiven auswirkungen die
diese veranstaltung auf touristische art
und weise mit sich bringt ich möchte
aber auch dort anknüpft die frau
bundesministerin schon angeführt hat die
steiermark hat mit der power auch die
möglichkeit sich als kompetenzregion im
bereich luft- und raumfahrt zu
positionieren denn die steiermark ist
bekannt als autoland was aber nicht so
bekannt ist ist dass unser mobilitäts
cluster art ist er mittlerweile bereits
80 unternehmen umfasst die sich mit dem
thema luft und raumfahrt beschäftigen
3.000 mitarbeiterinnen und mitarbeiter
sind in diesem bereich tätig und das
sage ich ihnen noch eine beeindruckende
zahl in 90 prozent aller flugzeuge
befindet sich technologie aus der
steiermark sei dass im bereich des
interieur sei es im bereich der technik
sei es sogar im bereich der fenster im
flugzeug also es gibt kaum einen bereich
wo nicht steirischer technologie
verankert ist und wir wollen die
airpower auch nützen um die steirischen
aber natürlich österreichischen und
internationalen unternehmen vor den
vorhang zu holen und auch darauf
hinzuweisen welche neuen technologien
stichwort green tech es in diesem
bereich gibt und welche
ausbildungsmöglichkeiten wir am standort
für den luftfahrtbereich haben und
erlauben sie mir auch den hinweis dass
gerade in der obersteiermark derzeit
große industrielle investitionen
stattfinden die ebenfalls sehr stark
durch den luftfahrtsektor ausgelöst sind
wir bekommen und ich glaube das ist auch
noch nicht so bekannt gerade ein neues
aerospace werk beispielsweise in
kapfenberg wenn ich schon bei der
industrie bin möchte ich gleich das
thema der dekarbonisierung ansprechen
also verringerung der co2 emissionen
denn das ist ein auftrag den wir sehr
ernst nehmen in der stadt wir forschen
sehr intensiv gemeinsam mit der
industrie an dem thema wie die
dekarbonisierung gelingen kann und wir
sind der meinung dass das alle
wirtschaftsbereiche umfassen
verständlich auch den tourismus
selbstverständlich auch
großveranstaltungen wie diese jetzt hat
die frau bundesministerin schon
ausgeführt dass hier keine zusätzliche
flugstunden stattfinden wird seitens des
österreichischen bundesheeres das heißt
der hauptteil der emissionen wird durch
die an und abreise der besucherinnen und
besucher ausgelöst jetzt betrifft das
nicht nur die airpower sondern das
betrifft jeder großveranstaltung die wir
durchführen sei dass im sportbereich die
special olympics sei das ein feste weil
sein dass kulturveranstaltungen und es
ist daher für mich auch ein politischer
auftrag zu untersuchen wie wir in
zukunft
großveranstaltungen klimaverträglich
durchführen können und ich bin sehr
dankbar dass die frau bundesministerin
mit ihrem team hier bei der airpower
bereits die ersten schritte umsetzt und
ich habe mich entschieden mit einem team
von steirischen forscherinnen und
forschern ein konzept zu erarbeiten wie
wir in den nächsten jahren
großveranstaltungen co2 reduzieren
durchführen können ich glaube das muss
uns gelingen dass wir auch in zukunft
wirtschaftliches fortkommen haben und
gleichzeitig das klima schützen das
werden wir im nächsten jahr auch schon
an zahlen demonstrieren können und ich
bedanke mich das sehr herzlich bei den
partnern dem österreichischen bundesheer
bei die freie liebe liebe frau
bundesministerin bei red bull und beim
einem koalitionspartner herzlichen dank
dh die airpower kann genauso gut ein
wegbereiter sein wie in zukunft groß
veranstaltungen abgehalten werden sollen
ja herr klubobmann
da bleibt auch die frage wie schätzen
sie den stellenwert und die bedeutung
dieser veranstaltung jetzt für
österreich ein für österreich meine sehr
verehrten damen und herren danke für die
einladung zu dieser pressekonferenz
freut mich dass ich hier sein darf es
ist für österreich die zweitgrößte
veranstaltung im jahr ist insofern ist
die erbauer ganz wichtig für österreich
aber natürlich vor allem auch für die
steiermark die von landesrätin eine frau
bundesminister wie bereits angesprochen
es geht um die um die regionen es geht
um der landesregierung seit vielen
jahren um die entwicklung der regionen
wenn man sich anschaut was in den
letzten jahren hier rund um den red bull
ring in spielberg gutes hat sich gut
entwickelt hat formel 1 motogp und und
vieles mehr so ist es ein ganz ein
wichtiger impuls für die region um es
also eine großartige veranstaltung jetzt
seit 2009 10 wieder gibt dann ist das
ein freudentag für die steiermark weil
es arbeitsplätze bringt für die region
weil es für den tourismus sehr wichtig
ist weil es bekanntheit bringt was ja in
weiterer folge auch ganz wichtig ist und
weiß vor allem auch wertschöpfung bringt
9 millionen euro wurden bereits
angesprochen also insofern ist das aus
meiner sicht eine win win situation für
die region und deswegen ein freudiger
tag dass das im nächsten jahr hier
stattfinden wird
meine damen und herren lassen sich auch
noch sagen natürlich weil denn die
nachhaltigkeits frage auch im vorfeld
schon ein thema war natürlich ist das
wichtig großveranstaltungen in zukunft
auch auf nachhaltigkeit hin zu verändern
und anders aufzusetzen und deswegen bin
ich sehr froh dass die frau
bundesministerin des bereits
angesprochen hat die von landesrätin es
bereits angesprochen hat dass man hier
auch maßstäbe für die zukunft setzen
kann bei dieser veranstaltung im rahmen
dieser erbauer auch neue wege gegangen
werden und ich bin felsenfest davon
überzeugt dass vor allem die frage der
an und abreise mit dem öffentlichen
verkehr mit bahn und dergleichen hier
bei der airpower gemeinsam mit den
partnern hier in vorbildlicher art und
weise umsetzung gebracht wird und das
ist ja auch wichtig aber für kommende
veranstaltungen dass man hier auch
maßstäbe für die zukunft in diesem
bereich setzt in diesem sinne danke
vielmals danke den partnern dem
österreichischen bundesheer red bull ich
freue mich auf die veranstaltung im
nächsten jahren kann es kaum erwarten
wenn man das wetter heute so anschaut
kann man nur hoffen dass das heute ein
dass es in einem jahr gleich schön ist
danke vielmals vielen dank herr
klubobmann ja dann bleiben wir gleich
zum thema partnerschaft herr magister
steuer red bull arbeitet schon seit
jahrzehnten mit den partnern
österreichisches bundesheer und dem land
steiermark zusammen was ist denn das
besondere an dieser langjährigen
partnerschaft
herzliches grüß gott von meiner seite an
alle damen herren und auch die werten
partner aber wie sie richtig sagen das
ist eine sehr langjährige zusammenarbeit
mittlerweile seit über 25 jahren und mit
voller wertschätzung alleine da ist das
schon mal was besonderes vor allem die
langjährig kite schon damals ist die
zielsetzung gewesen dass man eine
airshow von internationalem format in
die schöne steiermark bringt das war die
vision und wenige jahre später wurde die
airpower dann auch schon zur besten air
show europas gewählt und ist nur
deswegen gegangen weil sich die partner
auf augenhöhe getroffen hat und jeder
seine expertise eingebracht hat und zwar
diejenigen die er einfach von haus aus
mitbringt wir sind sehr unterschiedliche
partner und deswegen sehr
unterschiedliche stärken und die
zusammenbekommen bringen dann
schlussendlich auch die besondere
airshow die airpower hoffentlich auch
wieder 20 22 dass zum einen das
bundesheer mit dem organisationstalent
sicherheit luftfahrt internationale
kontakte das land steiermark mit der
gastfreundlichkeit der touristik der
kulinarik oder auch dem
wirtschaftsstandort und wir dürfen dann
von unserer seite auch noch die
marketing und kommunikationsexperte
einbringen darüber hinaus dürfen wir
auch immer zu dem flugprogramm
teilnehmen und so haben wir da unsere
flying bulls allen voran die sowohl im
static als auch im flying display immer
highlights setzen können der zivilen
luftfahrt zum einen und zum anderen
dürfen wir auch immer ein sehr
besonderes highlight bringen und zwar
das leiseste der airpower einmal am tag
bei der airpower wir das richtig leise
bekommt dann
da nur klassische musik und ein
segelflug team die planung zaubern ihre
künste in die luft das ist was
besonderes
und genau so versuchen wir uns auch
immer wieder innovationen
hineinzubringen und wären mit dem erotik
triple dem regulären patrick triple
nächstes jahr versuchen eine
weltpremiere zu feiern letztes mal hat
leider aus wetters technischen gründen
nicht geklappt flieger helikopter und
sky darüber miteinander in die luft zu
bringen wir werden es aber bei der
airpower 22 ein weiteres mal probieren
von unserer seite gibt es sehr viel
vorfreude auf die partnerschaft
vorfreude auf die veranstaltung
besonders auch immer die den clip sich
angeschaut hat dann sieht man was für
publikum vor ort ist es ist publikum von
jung bis alt die enkel sind mit den
großeltern familien jugendliche alle
sind ort und alle haben ein lächeln im
gesicht und genau das macht die airpower
schlussendlich aus deswegen vorher noch
wir uns bereits auf die airpower und
auch ein danke jetzt schon und die
partner und an die zukünftigen
vergangene zusammenarbeit sie wird es
gerade aufwachen lassen mit dem red bull
erotik triple können sie uns vielleicht
erklären was dieses manöver so besonders
macht an den rhein und riedmann unseren
chefpiloten übergeben der kann das etwas
profunder beantworten als meine
wenigkeit und ich den chefpiloten bitte
aufs podium bieten wir haben dann auch
ein eigenes micro für sie
ja was macht dieses manöver jetzt so
besonders es ist einfach eine
zusammenbringen von verschiedenen
disziplinen der luftfahrt das heißt das
beginnt mit der pro 105 das ist unser
hubschrauber
felix baumgartner davor diese tolle
vorführung fragen hat es mittlerweile
auch hier
die pro 100 filmen hatte keinen applaus
verdient
die bo 105 steigt die luft dann steigen
unsere fallschirmspringer aus und dann
beginnst richtig lustig zu werden
mittlerweile ist der merkur frei leben
der mit dem hubschrauber fliegt dann
flankiert worden von 15 40 aus einem
reinrassigen kunst flugzeug mario costa
fliegt das barrio costa vielleicht hat
der eine oder andere gehört ist jetzt
auch ziemlich bekannt worden durch einen
tunnel ritt den er begangen hat und
dann geht es darum dass eben diese
beiden
fluggeräte die eigentlich überhaupt
nicht zusammen passen also ein
hubschrauber und eine edge ein
kunstflieger der
die miteinander rollen machen also das
ist eigentlich das was eigentlich
unmöglich ist aber durch großes training
ist es gelungen dass wir das eben
durchführen kann und
dass das nicht alleine darum herum
tanzen dann die die fallschirmspringer
so wirklich ein spektakuläres ereignis
das heißt menschen maschine arbeiten
hier ganz mit höchster präzision zu sehr
wichtig es geht natürlich um die
maschinen aber auch um das trainieren
das training was natürlich da absolut
auch dazu gehört ja ja und was geht
jetzt im kopf eines piloten vor wenn er
sich das so nah am himmel in den lüften
bewegt ja es ist immer eine eine
großartigkeit wir sind jetzt katar am
letzten wochenende wieder einmal auf
einer großen air show gewesen
slowenischen er fest dass stattgefunden
hat und es ist immer wieder wirklich
schön wenn man die luft kommen kann
überhaupt nach dieser doch längeren
krise um hat doch eher zu hause
trainieren müssen und dass man sich
einfach wieder öffnen kann aber das
gleiche wieder in der heimat zu fliegen
und und hier in der steiermark wo
einfach die landschaft dann noch einmal
so schön ist und wenn man dann diese
loopings und kapriolen fliegt und dann
links rechts verbissen wahrnehmen kann
eben die die die schönen landschaften
nach der landung wenn man dann seine
loopings und rollen gemacht hat
informationen und so
an den zuschauerreihen vorbeirollt und
wirklich mitbekommt wie diese emotionen
eben da auch
mitspielen
wir machen ja viele er schoss aber so
dass richtig die die die hände in die
höhe gerissen wird ist eigentlich selten
wo und das ist bei der airpower absolut
gegeben und das ist natürlich
wunderschön wenn man dann das mitbekommt
weil während des displays kriegt er
nicht ganz das ambiente mit weil da ist
man hochkonzentriert aber danach also
wenn man dann so billig ist und
vorbeirollt und man merkt das hat auch
gefallen ja das ist natürlich schon eine
emotion die die absolut da ist ja dann
wird die erbauer eine veranstaltungen
mit vielen attraktionen von
militärischer und ziviler seite
gemeinsam mit 1 3 partner ja all die
informationen bekommen sie jetzt schon
auf der airpower 22 webseite das portal
können sich ab dem frühjahr
2022 akkreditieren aussteller gastro
stände können sich jetzt schon auf der
website vormerken lassen ja und jetzt
meine damen und herren der medien haben
sie die gelegenheit in einzelinterviews
ihrer persönlichen fragen zu stellen die
sie dann meine damen und herren die via
internet heute dabei sind dann
entsprechend medien nachlesen und
nachhören
können ja und somit wünsche ich allen
veranstaltern viel erfolg mit der
airpower 22 und ich freue mich dann
schon wenn sie alle mit dabei sind
dankeschön
[Musik]
[Applaus]